is ed sheeran married or not we hear
from the man himself plus why Kelly
Clarkson is still shocked fellow voice
coach Blake Shelton is with when Stefani
and we sit down with RuPaul drag race
all-star Trixie Mattel
hey guys this is the daily Deni and I've
got a couple quick hits for you right
off the bat so listen up yesterday I
told you about rumors that Ed Sheeran
got married in secret
that's right fans assume so because he's
been spotted with a ring on his left
finger well and set the record straight
to ITV at the BRIT Awards last night so
we can all rest easy with you are you
married number one
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's just like a cute little
commitment ring on your wedding finger
yeah you know I never saw why men didn't
wear engagement rings yes it's the same
commitment either way so yeah Tory made
it for me herself out of silver play
[Applause]
so there you have it folks who says men
can't show off their happily engaged
alright let's put something else to bed
real quick speaking of putting a ring on
it beehive I know we were all swarming
today after this surprise remix of
Beyonce's sweet dreams dropped it
appeared on title Apple music iTunes but
Color Me confused because the song is
for 2010 well listen as good as that
track is a rep for Beyonce does tell et
the remix was not authorized by her team
that being said it exists go enjoy it
just know Bibi herself didn't put it out
but it does go to show you how parched
we offer some music from Beyonce and you
know I'm also thirsty for this season of
The Voice I'm a sucker for these music
competition shows but the voice returns
this Monday with new coach Kelly
Clarkson and as our Sophie she lacy
found out Kelly and Blake Shelton are
already at war but for a very different
reason Kelly's husband Brandon
Blackstock is also Blake's longtime
manager whose team is he on the
socializing get awkward cuz I know y'all
hang out as couples right okay the first
time I saw Gwen's house it's insane
I got kind of like pretty woman walking
in the store except I didn't look like
Julia Roberts and I was walking in a
store and they were like you know long
here cuz it's like she's such a style
icon as well as like this amazing artist
and I literally talked about her house
with my husband for like hours I was
like I was like I felt like I was a good
interior decorator and then I walked
into Quinn's house well that makes me
that like why is she with him a shock
for you the first time you saw Gwen's
house yeah shocked to me that I got
invited to her house if you're still
super oh wait I just noticed I'm I'm
blocking a little Kelly Clarkson back
here my bad Kell are you guys if you're
still surprised Blake and Gwen are a
thing well so is heat I actually think
they're kind of kicked together you know
who else is cute together the America's
Got Talent
and thankfully all four of them simon
cowell howie mandel heidi klum and note
we are all set to return to a GT this
summer and Tyra Banks is coming back as
host 2 and it doesn't get more fierce
than that folks actually I stand
corrected because are you watching
RuPaul's Drag Race all-stars 3 I told
you this before but this show is as
entertaining as it comes it's America's
Next Top Model meats Project Runway
meets America's Got Talent
it's got it all and our Bryce Sanders
sat down with one of Mama Roos remaining
Queens with the T on the rest of the
season Vivi there is a theory online
that she is a mole working for the
judges to me the only mole on this
season is above Ben's lip and I think
she should get it looked at I'm
exceptionally beautiful there's a twist
coming as in laganja y'all wanted a
twist without revealing what the twist
is what was your reaction to learning
what the twist was the twist
what twist all I can say about that is
RuPaul's Drag Race all-stars 3 is coming
to your TVs in 2018 Oh
did it work no but I'll accept it you
know if I say anything close to a
spoiler a red dot will appear on my
forehead and we'll just your RuPaul
laughs from about 40 threatening my life
once again
all right there's still a lot of season
left to come yeah I know I fell on the
bottom once and I feel like everybody's
like you've really disappointed us I'm
like what's your one word to describe
what is still to come this season Oh
shocking shocking shocking my face at
the end of this elimination when I was
just staring shocked hey I mean I'm not
without giving away too much my shocked
face will come out again and again
Bryce also gave Trixie a little snatch
game rude emption by impersonating her
all-star three sisters Trixie did not
Bryce but click on the video right now
on this screen to check it out all right
guys that's it for today
love that tomorrow is already Friday so
we can talk some new music this week hit
subscribe on our channel and then we'll
groove tomorrow